item 1 of the agenda apologies for
absence oh I have to in the office
counselor Mountain and counselor autumn
are there any other apologies thank you
I understand councilman will be later
yep councillor Cooper thank you
they say count sir Leslie butcher thank
you item two is the minutes of the
extraordinary meeting held on the 12th
of February 2019 and the meeting held on
the 19th of February 2019
are those agreed members thank you
item 3 to receive declarations of
interest now good thank you very much
item 4 announcements from the Chairman
leader or head of page service the first
item falling within this item on the
agenda is the invitation to Malcolm
Richards from Gideon if you'd like to
come to the front of the dais
well well good evening ladies and
gentlemen counsellors it's joy to be
here I'm not going to take up much of
your time I saw a cop in the agenda you
know very believe things are I make my
remarks brief as you've just been told
is the idea as Isis Gideon's the local
kid Ian's I'll tell you about him us in
a moment to make a present end
presentation of especially inscribed
Bible to the leader of the council we do
it around the whole of Southeast ethics
the mayor of South End mayor council
point and chairman here
but in case you don't know about much
about Gideon's we're celebrating our
70th anniversary this year behind our
American counterpart they started the
work at the end of the 19th century and
we caught on with it in 1949 where we
know that far behind them but we're
catching up slowly and the idea is that
we go around to present copies of the
Bible either the whole Bible or smaller
copies to schools and other places you
may remember when you were at school
getting one a little bit like that wife
got one when she was at school a good
number of years ago I won't say how many
years but it was more than 5000 sorry
she was at that and her bun is it a
little bit better than this
the kids get one of these and I said to
them you know if in 50 years time it's
well worn and well used that's great
we're doing the schools in Rockford and
Rainey we've done Swain fits why mark
Greenwald and we got King Edmund to do
in June so let me get around go into a
fear of the local churches telling them
what we do why we do it and make the
presentations to them and get people to
become friends the Gideons that means
they can go subscribe to newsletters and
things like that but basically tonight
it's the means of giving out to your
chairman I know it's in the end of your
year of
whispered good time to do it that's
girls bird doesn't age what we do as I
said it started 17 years ago in England
and in case you think I was there at the
very first one I wasn't I'm really near
baby to the branch but we were coming on
the the date up 19th of February
everything was all prepared for them to
give it to but I think that was
cancelled and the guy who was going to
come and do the presentation is on
holiday so afraid you've got me so on
behalf of the local branch which is
southeast ethics were based around South
End area up as far as Oxford Rainey
cavi been freed Rickford large area 23
schools the hospitals nursing homes
hotels that's the other main one the big
brown one you usually find the hotel
draw which is very useful for propping
the window open if he's on a hot evening
but it's not really meant for that but
we've got one for you sir and we'd like
you to accept it with the wishes of a
local branch and hopefully after the
change you mentioned that come up in
what next week all night we'll be back
again to present you're successful so to
take this earth and its representatives
and rights for District Council
counselors their merit by Gideon's UK
South East Essex branch and it quotes a
verse from the Psalms is you may be
aware of your word is a lamp to my feet
and a light to my path so I hope you all
treasure it and use it and find out who
helped you
and in fact I do still have the line new
Testament which I received from school
and is a little bit more than 50 years
old
[Applause]
rest of the of the next item I would
just like to say a few words about three
members of this council who will not be
seeking re-election on Thursday
councillor John Mason councillor Ron
Odom and council Nick Cooper councillor
Mason has been a member since 2000 and
councillor autem since 2002 during which
time they have made most valued
contributions both inside and outside
this chamber having served on many
committees and subcommittees and
represented the council on a number of
outside bodies councillor Mason is
currently deputy leader of the Rockford
district residents and green group
having previously been leader of the
Rockford district residents group from
2005 to 2014 and a leader of the green
and Rockford district residents group
from 2014 to 2017 councilor Alton was
deputy leader of the Liberal Democrats
group from 2003 to 2007 teen during
their long service I have held them both
in high regard and their presence will
be missed
councillor Cooper has served as member
since 2 2016 on various committees and
in his short period as a member has
served as deputy leader firstly of the
UPA you could you could group and
currently deputy leader of the Friends
of Rochefort group I would like to take
this opportunity to thank them all for
the service they have respectively
provided and to wish them well in
whatever pursuits they choose to follow
now council cut more I understand that
you would also wish to say a few words
chairman as you have said we're going to
miss three counselors that are not
putting themselves forward for
re-election John and I first worked
together I think in 2009 he was here
elected originally yeah so we've been
together for 19 years if you like yes
we've been friends yes we've been
enemies but we've always had I think had
it done it with this little bit of a
smile most of the time and that's been
good John has made his real contribution
I think to the District Council
certainly in planning terms and
certainly in some of the work that we've
done with our business work as well so
I'd like to thank him for that and for
his work as a contribution as a leader
of a crew and as a deputy leader
councilor wrote some unfortunately isn't
here but I think he's worth you know
that he's been deputy leader of the
Liberal Democrats for quite some time
and there's also contributed to many of
the committee's that come forward and
councillor Cooper much the same Chairman
so I do endorse what you have said and
and I think they won't be missed by this
council but let's see what happens while
I have the stage can I say good luck to
all those that are taking part in the
elections coming up we might see some
different faces coming forward and then
we might see the same face he's coming
forward but they've seen the heads of
the electorate nice so I think it's less
than 36 hours now so let's wait and see
what happens but thank you chin thank
you can anybody else cancer Stanley
chairman councillors this is the last
meeting of the council report our local
elections
I would love to say a big thank you to
attach the john mason for his health
advice and friendship and on behalf
evident his voice and his presence will
be missed in the chamber and we wish you
all the best on these retirement and
also or
he's a he
he's a lucky man with his you know it's
always welcoming and he's always good
promise to us
good luck to him
as well hi Thank You chairman
you might seem strange bralette came I'm
prepared to say anything today because
John strictly forbade me from saying
anything on Saturday so a few people
have actually said you should say
something and I think they are right and
I'm going to disobey these instructions
as my former leader or glorious leader I
came to this council in 2010 very raw
very inexperienced and very uh
knowledgeable as we all are when we
become counselors I think Chris black
helped me a great deal but sitting next
to councilor Mason taught me even more
especially a few swear words which
troubles are sure I was allowed to know
which use the whispering a year now and
then to take me away I will keep this
brief but um over the years he's
contributed lock discounts as we all
know with you some technical technical
expertise on planning and on on Finance
from his days in the city
I've learnt an awful lot from him or
missing greatly in this chamber but I
will continue to see him outside as a
friend and I'd like to thank him for
everything he's done over the years
I can't possibly outshine a word about
Ron or a council writing because again
he was very welcoming along with all the
Lib Dems when I was first elected with
advice although over the years he may
have attended less I still see him quite
regularly at deputies and I'm sure I
will continue to do something Thank You
chairman thank you
councillor Oakley Thank You chairman I
think there's been a lot of very woman
and kind and welcoming words for the
counselors that are not going to be in
this chamber in next week but I just
like to say my my piece and I'll be very
brief counsel Cooper is someone who I've
met through the process of the you know
politics of the council but he's someone
who's a character who I've come to
appreciate and I look at him as a friend
likewise council Mason too because
different character but he's provided me
with a lot of help and assistance with
information and we've mattes to do we've
with the count on how how things operate
Ron I don't know as well but he's he's
managed to pass on a few kind words in
whispered in my ear and various of
different meetings most of which have
been very amusing and they will be sadly
missed and we need characters like
they're in this council and hopefully we
will we will find some new ones shortly
Thank You mr. Mason
Jared I'm deeply touched and I have to
say there's quite a few people in the
districts and in this council who think
I've been touched for years but know
that nevertheless it is an emotional
time this this final council this is the
third time I've actually retired not
from the council but other organizations
and other roles from banking from
greensward Academy and now from the
council
I've been lucky in that at almost every
point every retirement I've chosen my
time I've chosen my time myself with my
colleagues my wife and this is a plan
which I intended to follow I have been
incredibly honored by residents to have
elected me for so many successive
occasions clearly they they have trusted
me and I hope that I've carried out
their wishes as well as anybody could I
would also like to thank the officers of
the council not all of the officers of
the council are still with the council
but I can assure you that all of their
faces and advice you know flash before
my eyes
when I even come to think about those
who have helped me along the way they've
helped because there are stuff I don't
know
they've helped because the stuff I
needed urgently there's stuff that
residents needed and they've given it to
me and the council can come up trumps it
came up trumps through Sean in the last
few days and thank you the very last
issue of complaint
I hope that came from residents at least
I can respond to them the council does
care about it
it does care about what it's going to do
about it and that's the way the
council has related to its residence
throughout the term have been on the
council and I hope that continues I
would just like to say also thank you to
all the members who have listened to me
some of you I would have listened to me
with agreement some of you would have
listened to me with them strong
disagreement but nevertheless this has
been a cordial chamber as Terry says we
we may disagree on issues of policy on
issues of of determination and the way
forward but nevertheless we've been able
to conduct ourselves appropriately and
outside the chamber it's all forgotten
and that's something that I learnt from
Peter Webster who I sat next to for the
first two or three years of my my term
on the council and believe me that was
far more colorful
he was truly truly a remarkable man
and I took a great deal from him and
mavis thank you chairman thank you for
listening and thank you for your kind
thoughts
[Applause]
well now I'm delighted to be able to
announce that under item 5 of the agenda
that we are to receive a presentation
from the Rochford district Youth Council
and I've delighted to welcome to the
chamber this evening into this meeting
and perhaps I can invite them to come up
and give us their presentation
good evening thank you for taking time
out of your schedule to meet with us who
are we we are the watch with district
Youth Council our members include me
neighbours chair Rachel our Vice Chair
Georgia our press and media officer
Chloe our secretary and Lilly Mae our
treasurer as the Rochford District Youth
Council we would like to improve the
community have a positive impact on
people's lives with our projects and get
rid of the negative stereotypes around
teenagers we've started our first few
meetings getting to know each other as
we believe this was most important for
an effective working environment then we
looked around and searched for
activities and clubs for teenagers to
attend and realize there isn't actually
much for adolescents in the local area
we gave a survey out to a few schools
which helped us understand what young
people believed were the main problems
facing our society that needed to be
tackled we believe this survey was
important so that not only our voice can
be heard but so we actively represent
local youth using the results of this
survey we discovered that on average the
schools we surveyed were most concerned
about mental health and they started off
our first campaign as a Youth Council
good evening I'm Georgia and I'm going
to be talking to you about our mental
health campaign and why we chose this
topic every 90 minutes in the UK a life
is lost to suicide it doesn't
discriminate touching the lives of
people and every corner from the
homeless and unemployed to builders and
doctors to reality stars and footballers
it's the biggest killer of people under
the age of 35 more deadly than car
crashes and cancer yet it's rarely
spoken of a taboo that threatens to
continue with deadly rampage unless we
all stop and take notice now furthermore
mental health came back our most popular
response in our school surveys we
conducted in the early stages it beat
knife crime CSE and bullying meaning we
must listen and take action as a Youth
Council we then created a brief plan to
see how we would approach our campaign
and what we wanted to achieve we engage
with the mental health service provider
and the public health elite to agree
actions for the castle join and Rockford
health and well-being strategy which you
can see here on the slide on the right
and finally we have generated together
as the Youth Council no original and
exciting ideas these ideas such as
renting out or premises for young people
to go to and do activities such a table
tennis and a safe place for young people
to go to with their friends and mental
health trained sports coaches will be
present we will also like to develop our
social media pages further creating
videos raising awareness about mental
health and websites to help young people
we believe for our hard work and support
from the external community working
together we will achieve great things
that will have an amazing a positive
impact on people's lives
we will continue to focus and work on
our mental health campaign trying to
reach as many young people across the
district and impact real change we want
to increase the visibility of the Youth
Council by getting out into the
community attending events and sharing
our work we want to increase our
membership pretty short we have a strong
voice and to empower young people thank
you for taking your time to listen to us
and our ideas today we really appreciate
it you can help us to raise our profile
across the district by supporting your
campaigns and future plans you can sign
up for email alerts at the email on the
slide or follow us on Twitter and
Instagram like and share our post do you
have any questions
counsel mr. magician thank chairman and
excellent and in there no just say
lovely to see a bit of gold pal going on
out there and just out of interest um
I've got a friend who actually was one
of the original books reducible counsel
her name's Joanna Malpass she has been a
champion for mental health many years
she actually received an award from
Stephen Fry and she's done a few
pictures and films with ITV and there is
another channel but she's also now a
forensic psychologist with Westminster
University that goes to show how long
ago love to tie you in with her and
strangely she gave me some facts today
because they've been putting out news
and there's actually an 8% increase on
through the lights in under 25 so
absolutely anything we can do to help
you we're here to help you
brilliant well go girls
are there any other questions catcher
Smith Thank You chairman as you might
know we've got an election on Thursday
and a lot of people have been out
campaigning and one of the big issues
that's come across is anti-social
behavior and apparently it's all down to
the youth of today what you have to say
about that place in my opinion I believe
that it may be down to technology and
how it is and how it has advanced as it
is given us many ways of communicating
through different from forms and we now
have many many different ways of
communicating with different people from
all over so we may seem antisocial but
we may we may be talking to people all
over the world
and furthermore I believe but young
people do have the ability to become an
amazing great adults and to develop
their life into amazing career but I
believe they need this support to do
this they need to grow and have
knowledge from the elderly and older
people so therefore we believe that we
need to be taught in the right way to be
able to do this and I believe that
schools need to teach younger people how
to behave and how to do things and also
parents I believe pay plays a huge part
as you're with them for over half of
your day every day of your life every
year just whip thank you chairman I'd
like to thank the Youth Council for
joining us tonight
and forgive us an excellent presentation
I thought was important as a council we
continue to hear the voice of young
people and I just like to ask the youth
council how else would you guys get
involved in the council and to
contribute to the work that we try and
do across the district well in my
opinion I believe that we should be able
to help with some decision-making in
with the youths and about healthy eating
and bits like that as it will affect us
in the future as to what decisions are
being made now and you're also should
show that you have the strength you are
able to communicate with the youth and
taking their opinions
calories
Thank You Jay
well done I think we've actually seen
tonight in the chamber here the
potential that there is in the youth
here and I hope that this is the first
of many presentations that you give to
this council and I wish you every bit of
luck going forward on this I would like
to say a big thank you I've been
following this group right from the
outset this time around and Kelly and
Tracy have put in a huge amount of
effort to this and they should be part
of the thanks for that but I'd also like
to take the opportunity to ask each of
us to actually step up to the platform
here because you see there are only a
small group they need encouragement we
individually can encourage them but we
can also encourage those around who we
know sons daughters grand grandkids
friends around we've got kids who are in
this young adult age who can actually
influence this area for good you know we
need a bit of a change from the old
duffers that we've got in here sometimes
these people are bringing something
fresh to the council here and they
should could be commended for that and
I'd like to thank you for actually
stepping forward I know it's a bit of a
thing these days to be getting involved
in politics but you are actually
bringing something fresh to us and I
thank you for that so it's not a
question but I believe that needed to be
said thank you
Thank You chairman very well presented
and one thing that I would say to you is
that I hope that this is not gonna be
the only time that you come and visit
the council chamber these are public
meetings and they're open to the public
and that also means some of the other
meetings the council has as well so if
there is a matter for which you have a
general interest or something very
specific that you want to want to find
out more information about please come
along to council meetings they are open
to you Thank You councillor couple more
thank you Jim through you - a thank you
very much for your presentation one
thing I think that we've always tried to
do as a council is to make a difference
and I think the work that you're doing
is actually going to make a difference
to the youth of today and as they get
older to those that follow but the
question I would ask you if I may is
we're all councillors now do you see
yourselves as the councillors of
tomorrow I think certainly for you this
is the right track to be on to get the
experience before getting up with you
lot this is quite a scary thing but yeah
this is something that we are all
interested in which is why we are here
and definitely this is somewhere we
could see ourselves otherwise we
wouldn't be here Casa Lucas cool
Thank You chairman just wonder if it
might be an idea if some of these young
ladies would care to shadow some holders
to see what they do
certainly not to keep that we think that
would take
we do need to just be a little bit more
aware that some people's they have
public things going on including
imminent
and I think perhaps that's something
that might be discussed as a future date
and in more detail
to
sure
thank you very much councillor Stanley
Thank You chairman it's nice to see
killed power up there I must of me but
there's also I think it's 36% of
suicides or mouths young males under 36
years of age the pressures on
young people as we already know and have
you got any young males on your
committee or will you have any young
males on your committee in the future
and we have a list yet but we would like
to advertise out to obviously males as
well to make it a wider
councilman just like females that's not
what we intended to do and we would also
like mouse then we can get different
opinions from both sides which would be
much more helpful because we believe
from different genders there obviously
there is obviously different opinions
and then through our campaign will
advertise further and we do believe and
boys will start to join our campaign as
we have a few more joining in our next
meeting council misinformation
that louder voice we were obviously
aware as counselors about the activities
that you're undertaking but we get a lot
of information given to us is I'm sure
you're appreciating but that your
presentation tonight has been
exceptionally informative it's been
interesting and it's been impressive and
you should be very proud of yourselves
for doing that the one thing I would ask
is we get as counselors we get an
inordinate amount of communications and
most of it is from a general source
which means we tend to classify by where
it's come from if you have anything that
you want help with while you're
undertaking this if you write to us
please write individually with your
names rather than as a group I'm not
saying don't say watch everything else
but that way we will pick it up much
quicker much easier but anything we can
do to assist you it doesn't matter how
little it is just ask because if you
don't ask we won't know that you need
that help
so please that's my one request of you
but do be very proud of what you've
achieved so far thank you and keep up
the good work
I see no other hands raised thank you
very much I'm sure it's been quite an
ordeal for you standing up there and
talking to us and you've done extremely
well I've got news for you it gets
pretty scary sitting up here so but
thank you so much more than welcome to
stay for the rest of the meeting
although I think you're being collected
thank you so much for helping okay well
we now move to item six public questions
and member questions on notice there's
none item 7 business from the last
council meeting there's none
item 8 to note the minutes of executive
and committee meetings held between the
periods 2nd February to 19th April 2019
as listed those noted members and we now
move on to item 9 to consider a report
from the executives executive and
committees to counsel 9.1 report to the
review committee counselor person would
you like to introduce that Thank You
chairman members will be aware that a
project team formed of members of the
review committee have been undertaken
the rather extensive and at times
challenging task of reviewing the
Constitution which was considered to be
rather overdue with the assistance and
guidance of Paul cows and Angela law
this latest review and the subsequent
amendments that are proposed within this
report is the fourth and final section
of the review I would personally like to
thank both members of the project team
along with Paul and Angela for their
patience and determination it's a
complete review which as I have already
mentioned was it was a rather lengthy
and detailed process the latest proposed
changes have been considered and agreed
by members of the review committee and
we would ask that these changes are
adopted by for council this evening if
any members have any questions or
queries and at a law myself or the
chairman of the working party I believe
would be happy to address them
do you want to make any person to
counter steps one small item I think
it's probably just a typo on page nine
one three nine point one point six six
item nine D give you a chance to find it
okay the second line from the end
starting working groups will not meet in
public I think after that at that point
there there should be another not not
have public agendas and officers confirm
that that's new that can be put in
that would seem members are happy with
that great thank you did you indicate
but counsel Hawaii yes yes
Thank You chairman obviously I was on
reviewed which we do swing through I'm a
bit disappointed to say that some of the
corrections are one of the corrections
at least the I raise has not been
corrected so I'm just concerned other
Corrections may not also be correctly
because I know there are not very few
rights at the time one of which I can't
remember which on dope or cows was aware
of so I'm looking at getting the review
committee as well the one in particular
that's sprung out and I'll reread this
again for about the fourth time so I
produced I'll keep getting it wrong is
there's a wrestling from October sorry
about that again to refer to counselor
step those points on the plates for a
minute on page nine point one point two
zero so we'll stop the page s there's a
reference to say by way of personal
explanation C paragraph fifteen point
three this was raised at the review
committee so and I answered a what these
Corrections were going to be made prior
to today obviously fifteen point three
refers to a second as speech which is
not person explanation person
explanation it's between point one three
and so I'm just a bit concerned there
might be other errors like that within
the Constitution still which haven't
been corrected thank you cheering I
understand that what is indeed a
typographical error and should be 0.13
so again we will amend that
well that choice chairman will that be
the same will well third review
committee minutes be reviewed by into
the law to make sure that all of those
questions are in place then if they're
not in place and and I trust members are
happy for items which are simply
typographical errors for them to be made
as they go through surely per our
Constitution they should come back to
this committee there's no definition of
minor as I understand it thank you
well if I should say minor and obvious
you're not happy with that counsel is
miss Mason mr. chairman you'll probably
be unaware that the working party spent
I think three or four sessions trying to
ascertain a definition of minor for the
Constitution it was deemed by the legal
officer not to be possible very nice
therefore I share the other members
concern that any alterations should come
through full council ultimately to be
approved
there we have set up under the working
group I'm sure the Chairman will forgive
me for answering or needs to be helped
but we have set up where there's a
technical alteration perhaps in a name
not mine because we can't call it minor
because we can't define it that those
alterations for expediency will go first
to the standards committee to check that
they're not there's no errors which of
course then and then in full time go
through to full council to be adopted
this is the only body that can approve
any alteration to the Constitution the
other reasoning for that was that I'm
sure we've all got the Constitution and
it's got dates all over the place you've
got different dates on the same pages is
confusing and what has been determined
to facilitate changes in the future is
that once it's approved through full
council obviously the pages will be
reprinted with that date on that full
council date so that in future we can
trace back the changes to the
Constitution and there won't be errors
that have been made in the past
perpetuated so I'm sorry for such a
lengthy explanation but I hope that
clarifies the matter for you mr.
chairman Thank You Don
yes chairman just just for clarity our
members asking me to bring back this
report to the next council meeting and
have this approved at next council
meeting once it's all been checked
through so great members okay so they'll
be referred to defer to the next council
meeting
right we move on then to item 9.2
council Burton Thank You chairman um
hopefully members would've had a chance
to have a look at the review committee
annual report the review committee
continues to look at and discuss a wide
range of topics as members can see
slightly disappointing that no items
came before the committee this year it
was suggested by members of the public
as have done in previous years and
perhaps the council but take note of
this and look to raise awareness of this
ongoing invitation to our residents and
businesses during the next municipal
year as the current chairman of the
review committee I would personally like
to thank all the members of the review
committee for their continued support
and hard work over the past 12 months in
particular to councilor sparing and his
role as vice-chairman and also to both
pork ours and Michele power for their
continued assistance at input and I hope
that the full council will accept the
recommendation or does anybody have any
questions
councillor Kaplan not a recommendation
chairman but just to thank the chairman
of the committee and all the community
members for the work that they've done I
think we've seen some of that work
within the Constitution that's come
forward a very complicated document that
clearly you know he's worthy of some
real work and I know some real work was
done on that and I thank everybody who
actually contributed to that but I think
we need to acknowledge the work of the
review committee for this year and thank
them
Thank You chairman Thank You counsel so
in the absence of any other members
wishing to speak the recommendation that
is that is just proposed the council
resolves to receive the annual report as
amended is that a great members 9.3
council couple Thank You chairman yes
this became in front of the executive as
we had a meeting for the appointments
committee as there was a vacancy that
really needed feeling urgently and this
committee actually met on Monday I
appreciate that is he slightly
retrospective but it had to happen that
way because really we had to fill the
vacancy but I'm sure if there are any
questions and members will ask them but
I do agree with the recommendation thank
you Jim
any questions members council hi I'm
sorry um I have to place them to some
extent amazing director on this
Malathi know those unanswered steel I
was aware of this committee because I
was invited to sit on this committee on
Monday I'll take it from what the
counselor cut more I said that the
committee was actually met as in as
membership based on one point three my
problems with this stem from the fact
that the committee itself is
unconstitutional it's been appointed
unconstitutionally and furthermore it's
not pro rata the only body which can
appoint the chief officers at the
appointments committee
he's full of counsel the executive
variety I know I know unable to do so
it's not within the Constitution to
allow them to do that in addition this
committee has been most based on
membership of of the previous municipal
year and the pro is pro rata based on
that municipal year not pro rata based
on the membership of this council as it
was on the 29
April or the previous fall council even
and as you're aware I went in to be
extensive arguments with them mr. boss
stopped when he was here about program
sir rules and how we disagreed with them
I don't see how this council can now go
back and agree the programs rules as I
said they should be rather than how they
were determined that the last full
council would so determined at the
Proteas not program sir it's not
possible to eat this committee to exist
on this basis and based on that I don't
see how any decision made by that
committee can be legal oh it's take use
the words in front of at least two
slices on we're not sure if any other
ministers but Omar was always talked
about ultra virus outside their power
which I believe this case I could be
corrected but that's my view therefore I
cannot support this motion I think I
think it is not a more illegally
constituted committee thank you
chairman as I understand that the
committee is pro-rata the decision of
the chief appointments committee is
legal it's been through a robust process
this council is only asking to
constitute the committee and not make
comments on the decision of that chief
appointments committee carries a mrs.
Mason the only person the only people
that have power to appoint a full
committee of the council is the council
yet this committee has been set up has
apparently met without any approval I
don't believe that it is Parata if you
look at the other situations certainly
by determining who sits on that
committee that is wrong constitutionally
it is up to the groups to nominate
members to sit on committees it is not
up to the council to determine you do
not have that right therefore any
meeting that's been held with that sort
of determination by determining pre
determining ho people which groups
members of which groups will sit on that
that committee is wrong it's flawed and
therefore any decision that's made is
flawed
and I must admit I can't understand the
urgency they met yesterday today is full
counsel
what's wrong with meeting tomorrow what
was wrong with two days what made it so
urgent
that the executive had to make this
decision without as far as I'm concerned
proper power proper authority or due
regard to the normal process of the
council I was sorry but I do not think
that we should accept any decision made
and I certainly won't be supporting this
report it is fundamentally flawed thank
you I think as mrs. made from the the
only point I would make is that as I
understand it you're questioning the
decision having been made yesterday
whereas this particular recommendation
is really really to constitute the
committee right mr. chairman for clarity
this recommendation is wrong in itself
because the council is trying to
determine which members of the groups
can attend a committee it is not within
their power it is up to the group
leaders to determine which of their
members serve on which committees
therefore this is flawed in itself any
decision I know you don't want to
discuss the decision yesterday but I'm
hoping it won't be enacted because I
think it was fundamentally wrong that it
even matter but it is a different is it
stems from this failure the failure of
the council to put this committee in
place last May it stems from the failure
to do something in a timely fashion but
this recommendation is wrong because you
cannot name the members and say that
they will be part of that group and that
is what happened and you have a match I
mean if there was a meeting yesterday
where all members invited
now mr. Hoyt thank you just to clarify I
think you need to be split up into
confusion
not on our side on us say the Committee
which met yesterday which has been
confirmed by councilor cut law was based
on the committee membership has shown
here that committee membership he's not
legal that committee was not legal by
law and by a constitution
chairman the committee membership I
believe in the recommendation was
although those names in 1.3 refer to
specific councils I believe the
recommendation in 2.1 was referred
thrown to pro rata rules with regards to
the parties I have I understand from the
offices that all group leaders were
approached with regards to who would
like to attend this who would they like
to put forward on this committee we are
here to constitute this committee the
decision itself made by the chief
appointments committee went through a
robust process and it was not flawed it
was a fair process and a decision has
been made by that committee thank you
Kevin
I must earn clarify that I was not
approached as group leader to see which
members would be honest the committee I
was sent correspondence stating who was
on that committee by a decision made by
the executive earlier this month
and at no point was it suggested that we
would we had any input into this the on
the rules based on the last time that
there was a change of party and group
membership who nothing when cancer FD
became a conservative the pro rata rules
meant this committee now he's not pro
rata based on the rules discussed at
that time which I extensively this dust
with mr. Bostock thank you Thank You
chairman I just like to ask a question
of our legal officer in regards to this
matter prior to the meeting that took
place yesterday when was the last time
that this committee met to make a
decision about an
appointments Thank You mr. Shawn
so was that was that prior to the
reconstitution of the council as in the
last time the council was reconstituted
with the new pro rata rules sorry
chairman there was no new pro rata rules
the pro rata rules are the pro rata
rules if if the member can clarify the
question please
in in relation to the change of the
council from the elections and any any
other changes from members who may have
changed their political allegiance shall
we say I think that this has already
been brought up that there was a meeting
where this was discussed about the
situation about the pro rata situation
so had the head of this committee met
since then or was that you talking about
the last time that it met prior to that
situation sorry counselor could you just
repeat that question one more time
thank you I try and be a little bit
clearer you stated that the committee
last time it met was in 2017 was that
prior to the reconstitution of the
council after the last year's elections
or was that after that because what what
is being stated by other councillors is
that if if the membership of that
committee is just carried over we
haven't had the opportunity to as
leaders of our groups to change or alter
the membership of that committee to
reflect the new situation
appreciate well the chairman Oh like it
says it as far as I'm aware the the last
meeting of the chief officer
appointments panel was 2017 I think it's
towards the end of 2017 I can't recall
the exact date that that was prior to
the last election in 2018 cancer Stanley
Thank You chairman yes I did read the
notice off of the executive but I wasn't
contacted as to what member of the party
was going to be on that executive so I
wasn't actually contacted Thank You
Burton Thank You chairman I've heard
what other councillors have had to say
it's evening and I happy what I tend to
agree with counselor mrs. Mason and
counselor mr. hoi I think it's clear
that there's an issue here and I think
the council by having the meeting
yesterday have overstepped the mark if
we put it that way however I don't
actually have a huge issue with the
recommendation that's being made it is
asking us whether or not we agree for a
committee to Quebec convened on the
basis of previous membership and I think
we do have to take a common-sense
approach as well and I don't think that
whether the meeting was held yesterday
or tomorrow the decision from that
meeting would be the same I would I
therefore I take on board what counsel
mrs. Mason councilor who are saying
tonight and I do agree with them but at
the same time I think we do have to look
at this recommendation this evening with
the view to that and I think there are
two slightly separate issues although I
do agree with counselor mrs. Mason and
council
boy well I think we do need to have a
bit of a common-sense approach as well
happened thank you
cancer mr. Mason Thank You chairman up
in listening carefully I hope everybody
else says I can't support the
recommendation there's emanated from the
executive because constitutionally the
executive does not have the power to do
that
and therefore if it doesn't have the
power to do that I can't possibly and
knock on this council accept a
recommendation what we're doing or what
the council is proposing to do through
the executive is just role in the face
of the of the Constitution and ignore it
for convenience I do not know why there
is any great urgency in this matter that
could not have been stayed for a period
of 24 hours for this council as it
stands here sits sands here today to
actually agree to a proposal for a new a
new chief appointments committee as
constituted and I'll use their word
properly as constituted in accordance
with the pro rata rules
it is not whatever way you look at it
but I return to the point the point is
the executive does not under any
Constitution have the power to do this
if it doesn't have the power to do it
this council cannot endorse it accept it
pass it thank you Jim Thank You counsel
if I may because you have had quite Judy
what I'm going to say is as ever
counselor mr. Mason because it's much
more I couldn't leave in I could gather
Smith Thank You chairman I've listened
to the argument that's been pertinent
counsel hi and I I understand the gist
of what they're saying but equally I've
listened to our experienced professional
officer who has given formal
professional advice to the counsel and
that is that the decision is in order so
therefore I would like to move the
recommendation is printed on two point
one
I'm sorry yes please do
Chairman I have the agenda of the
executive that met on the 3rd of April
and I'll read some words from it if I
may and this is this is what became
before the executive there are no names
on here or groups or whatever it says
decision being recommended that a chief
officer appointments committee be
constituted for the current municipal
year comprising the same membership as
the previous municipal year to support
the recruitment of the vacant assistant
director post pending confirmation by
for council that's what it says the
reason for the recommendation it was not
anticipated that the chief officer
appointments committee would need to
convene during the current municipal
year therefore it was not constituted at
annual council in 2018 the recent
departure of two of the assistant
directors and the head of finance led to
a restructure of the leadership team
there is now a vacancy for an assistant
director resources in order to provide
leadership and resilience in this
service area it is recommended an
appointment be made as soon as possible
before the end of the municipal year
that was the recommendation that came
before the executive chairman and we've
taken legal advice from a legal officer
on that thank you I think we've I mean I
think everybody's headed I'm just just
very briefly
something I said anything
Chairman that that was my that was my
understanding I can't see no more than
that chairman oh I don't think it's
appropriate for me to discuss you know
the information I've been given a name
by named - named officers I think I'm
going to bring the discussion to a halt
I'll be very brief just for clarity we
have a motion yep just for clarity I was
was not directly contacted in relation
to this matter
thank you we have a motion on the
thought all those in favor
[Music]
numbers alright thank you
councillor Burton
councillor Carter
counselor cut more
councilor canal
councillor Dre for councillor FD
canceller Yves
counselor mrs. pudding
counselor Griffin
councillor Hazelwood councillor hook way
counselor mrs. hoi council ahoy
councillor Hudson
council you are new counselor Lucas Gill
councillor mrs lammle counselor mrs.
Mason
councillor Mason
counselor mrs. McPherson
councillor Mirek for
counts in a mill
counselor mrs. Pavlin counselor mrs.
Rowe counselor mrs. Shaw counselor shore
counts on a Smith counselor sparing
counselors Stanley counselor Steptoe
councillor Ward council a web counselor
mrs. Weston counselor Williams counselor
Wilson
chairman we have 25 for 9 against and 1
abstention the resolution in on 2.1 is
therefore fast-paced chairman as this
committee hasn't been opposed to shoot
it now because the vote the club
committees must be constituted by
agreement of four counts or in
accordance with the wishes of each of
the groups that's clearly not the case
pasted from the vote so I don't see how
that can now be legally constituted
Thank You Caroline the resolution has
been thirst
very strange I will be taking this
matter to local government Ombudsman
form an administration which it is
clearly according to their constitution
Gill
item 10 report on urgent decisions there
is none item 11 the report of the leader
on the work of the executive castro
companies
have I missed something
yeah
iiiiii to be leaven report on the leave
of thee
chairman this is the fifth and final
ordinary council meeting of the 2018-19
units per year and like to welcome all
members since the meeting on the 19th of
February the executive has met once
during which considerations included the
noting of projects program management of
his dashboard which forms part of the
assurance work for gold silver and
bronze project a recommendation to
council the chief officer appointments
committee be constituted for the current
municipal year comprising the same
membership as the previous municipal
year to support the recruitment of the
vacant assistant director post a
resolution of the council's materials
recovery facilities contract with Vera
door be extended for a further 18 months
other matters that my executive
colleagues and I have dealt with include
approving the timetable of meetings for
the 2019 25 minutes per year agreeing
the implementation of non means testing
pertaining to disabled facilities grants
who works up to the value of 5000 pounds
and Essex occupational therapists in
housing referrals agreement to a revised
corporate debt and write-off policy for
Oxford District Council a decision that
a formal response to Brentwood Borough
Council's consultation on its local plan
pre submission draft regulation 19 be
submitted and decision that the formal
responses to South in Borough Council's
and thorough Borough Council's
consultation on their local plan issues
and options regulation 18 be submitted
as always chairman I'll be happy to take
any questions for members in respect to
the work of the executive I'm sure my
executive colleagues will be happy to
contribute where appropriate thank you
Jim a point of order please chairman
sorry chairman I understand that we've
missed item 10 report on urgent
decisions no I did say report an urgent
decisions there is none
I do beg your pardon I stand corrected
Thank You counselor mrs. Weston if I
could just then refer back to item 10
report and urgent decisions this is to
be noted is that noted members thank you
my apologies
item 12 motions on notice that catalyses
measure now I have severe any questions
and the word any so you have a question
very well please proceed
authority to do so I'd like an
explanation please seeing is it we
couldn't take it under the other
recommendation we can certainly take it
under the work of the executive if
they've called a meeting which they had
not got the constitutional right to do
so I'd like an explanation do you wish
to respond to that counselor well I
think our services motion is referring
back to the the issue relating to the
chief officers appointments committee
should I care if I for the leader that
the executive made an arrangement they
notified certain people at their
discretion or someone's discretion but
what they've advised us through the
managing director that the people the
group leaders were invited asked about
it which apparently is a mistake shall
we say certainly doesn't appear to be
true but that meeting was arranged on
the instruction of the executive they've
held a meeting they've gone through a
process and as far as I can see they had
no power to do that I'd like a full
explanation Thank You chairman I think
I've already read out the agenda the
member he's talking about here and
exactly what came in front of us there
were no names on that I understood that
people were invited to that meeting and
didn't actually attend it so that's
that's not for me to answer to
but these these are the information that
we were given by officers we were told
it was formal agreed and there was no
problem in law as we have been told
again tonight thank you come back on
that I appreciate so council cup always
reading with the he's a gender again but
certain people were invited other
members of the council were not even
acknowledged there was no power for
anyone to in select eight members for
any reason and asked them to carry out a
function without the power of full
council
they had no right as far as I can see to
do that and that is not being clarified
being on the agenda is not an excuse for
the action chairman I'll repeat again
there were no names groups or anything
on the agenda that we saw it was merely
clarifying what I've already read it up
thank you chew through the chair would
he like to explain how the people got
invited if there were no names how come
eight people got invited and thirty-one
didn't I'll say again chairman we were
told this was a legal item that we could
take forward the process went through
and it does say the names that were
actually constituted in the previous
meeting I think it says in 2018 so you
know we've already gone through this
chairman and the motion has been passed
so we're really just going over old
ground and we can go round of the
circles like this for every phone I'm
wrong Council couple but it seems to me
that the what what is being said is that
the members of the committee were the
same as previously and that they had
been caught that had that had been
properly constituted at that time and it
was therefore merely a repetition is
that correct
so so there
Gemini's understand group leaders were
asked and invite and us and were invited
to put forward members for this
committee where it says with regards
comprising of the same membership I
believe that's with regards to the pro
rata on the political element rather
than the individual names so the I have
been informed that group leaders were
invited to put forward members to that
committee sorry on a point of already
must intervene because that is
absolutely not the case I was never
invited for board members I was received
an email which was a fait accompli that
the people named on that email were
members of the committee and that had
already been decided
thank you again point of personal
clarification I have no no intention at
all of leaving this chamber without with
with anything that is unclarified leader
referred to certain members we drew or
did not attend the chief appointments
committee I didn't attend that committee
chairman and because I intend to take
this to the local government Ombudsman
the reason I did not attend is because
it was not constitutionally enabled it
was enabled by the executive which has
no power so therefore I had no power and
I had no wish to attend Thank You
chairman that is a personal
clarification which will appear thank
you sorry for personal clarifications
when I think them example is right now
think I have a right of personal
clarification generally mentioned it's
not my neighbor I did not attend for the
same reason
Thank You chairman it would seem that
the issue that is being raised is a
matter for which the leader of the
council has actually stated the
executive made a decision to a
recommendation for the creation of a
appointments committee and that is
there's obviously sound reasons for that
but he then states from reading from the
agenda that it was the executive that
made the decision that the committee
would be the site the recommendation
would be for the same membership as the
previous one and that is there that is
the issue is the executive making that
this making that recommendation and
putting that forward for a decision
which is the matter which is not it does
not seem to fit with the Constitution it
is for the members of the group leaders
to put forward members to that committee
and that is the matter for which it
seems to be a unanimous on this side of
the chamber that none of the group
leaders were involved with making
appointments to that committee it was
just the previous committee as it met
last time and those names were then put
forward I think we are we are going
round and round in circles aren't we I
think the decision has been made and we
are going to pass on and if there are
any issues to be raised then these will
have to be discussed outside the meeting
I'm going to continue now motions on
notice there's none item 13 the pay
policy statement and ask mr. Stratton to
chairman just simply am required to
report the pay policy statement annually
to counsel there's some minor amendments
to salaries and so on relating to
cost-of-living increases that's the pay
policy Thank You chairman
councillor caramel-y yeah this is a
statutory note that has to come forward
from counsel which is why it's coming
for wouldn't've right now as you can see
I think I can say that our policy and
the grading structure that we have
actually fits quite well in comparison
to other councils locally which have
been criticized for their salary
structure at the senior in so I'm
pleased to say that we don't actually
come under that all and I think I think
it follows through exactly where we want
to be thank you Jim
Thank You councillor high-pitch ever
just NYC's you want to think under three
point six which I think was introduced
last year he's talked about Norfolk's
occupants which are only babbling within
the planning and regeneration service
cannot confirm if we are actually paying
at all Thank You chairman yes we are
yeah the recruitment of planning
officers remains a challenge for most
local authorities in in in Essex and
therefore the market supplement is being
paid at the moment
justice has this been helpful in
retaining staff thank chairman Arthur I
think so it we haven't been paying it
for a great length of time but I think
the signs are looking quite quite
positive at the moment in terms of the
the stability of the of the staff within
the development management section in
particular so we'll just have to see
what what how that Luke's over things
over the next few months but at the
moment the signs are looking very
positive okay members the recommendation
is that council result at the pay policy
statement be adopted all those in favor
agreed or anyone against good that is
adopted then that being the last item on
the agenda or don't think of it don't
think I'm going to use that clock the
I'm now meet close the meeting at 5:00
to 9:00 thank you for attending papers
please be upstanding well sir